Welcome to toxic Google and
Cambridge, Massachusetts. Uh,
today I'm very pleased to have here,
uh,
on by Gund speaking on
data for the people.
A topic that's a very close to us,
very familiar to us, of course,
and, you know, very
broadly speaking, does it,
there's a couple of ways
to go with this topic.
Obviously we are very generous with
our data and both explicitly and, uh,
and just in the normal course
of living in the modern world.
And we get back a lot for that.
And some people might argue that we don't
get back enough or, or, or whatever.
And so one way to go is kind of the,
the negative direction of controlling it,
uh, privacy, micropayments,
all that sort of thing.
The other direction is to be
much more open and positive, um,
to embrace this and then see we can
maximize the benefit we get from data.
I think a ladder is broadly,
uh, on today's his approach.
But of course, you know,
there are dangers, uh, uh,
there are things we can do to make
this work as well as possible for our,
for us as individuals. And, uh, um,
that'll be the topic for today and stuff.
Something that had done the is there's
a lot of experience with, um, but,
but rather than doing
a conventional, um, uh,
introduction I think will make this a
little bit more interactive and dynamic.
Like let's talk in general. So a, so
please contact us, welcome to Google
and welcome to the social data
revolution because ultimately,
not only is this the title
of my Youtube Channel,
but ultimately really that is
the amazing world we live in.
So reading the book, you started
life actually as a, as a physicist.
And so how did you come
to be what you are today?
So I got my phd in physics at Stanford
and I've always been a data person.
I was at soon as an undergraduate.
It was really amazing to be logged in to
other computers and that was way before
the web was invented. And, uh,
then I went to my phd advisor,
my initial Phd Advisor at slack,
the Stanford Linear Accelerator Center,
and told him, Jonathan, you know,
I really thought about it and I'm more
interested in newer networks that in
particle physics. So he
said, okay, what is that?
And he thought, you know, poking Alec
Tours in new monkeys or something. No, no,
it's about learning from data and that,
you know, he could live with. And uh,
he was super generous to then next
year you still support me for a while.
And then my phd with Dave rumor
heart who are some people you know,
really think was the one who pushed
the idea of neural networks. And uh,
that's what my phd and so machine
learning as would call it now,
lots of people in the world
and know about it now.
Those days were just a few of us.
[inaudible] Facebook's neuronetworks
stuff now was one of my friends.
So, um, it was a very smooth transition.
The transition from,
you know, doing physics,
which I still love and I will say
once if it's just always visits.
If you think like a physicist, then you
have actually a couple of attributes.
One is you don't run away from
data but you run towards data.
So sometimes when I talk to people from
the tend to intelligence community,
they would tell me that
I would be terrible agent
because when I see something
sketchy I always, you know, want
to see what's happening there.
Like sketchy data for instance,
where you need to interpret the
data and fill in some meaning.
Second thing physicists do is that
they're pretty good in what I call data
literacy. So for me, data
literacy is that, you know,
order of magnitude calculations,
you know,
what can be the case in what can't be
the case as opposed to my brothers.
I was a physicist and he says when
there's computer science Grad students,
they always come and say,
oh,
the algorithm is already converging
with the least significant digit.
So physicists, they know
about numbers, they love data.
And the most important thing is I
think they love experiments. So,
uh, at some stage 2001, 2002,
a phone rang and the headhunter was on
the line and he said that Jeff Bezos
would like to have a chief scientist.
And I try to figure out why I'd never
worked in a real company and why would I
want to work leave university.
We're going to company.
And so it turns out the Jeff,
of course,
a new from previously being a
de show how important data is,
but what he can do in retail of course,
as opposed to in finance where it
can be expensive as experiments.
So just like Google,
we,
when I was at Amazon and of course
afterwards have done tens of thousands of
experiments and you probably all know
many stories and maybe I leave some for
the Q and a if we still have time.
Um,
I was also wanted to be a
bit more interactive in that.
So then after Amazon I
went back to teaching.
I love teaching and I have to say I
teach one course a year at UC Berkeley
called social data revolution. And, uh,
it is just amazing to have the opportunity
to basically have the university is a
platform where once a
week for 10 weeks or so,
very smart students sit there and they
actually listen to you and the debug your
thoughts and then you see when
it's really painful for them.
If you don't know how to do something
on Facebook, like then, you know,
they just help you out and
they explain it to you.
So I think it's a great deal as a
wonderful way to spend your life.
And then however it doesn't scale.
So scaling is important.
And that's when I got the idea to actually
write the book about three years ago,
a little bit more than three years ago.
And the book I then want you to write has
been compressed into the chapter seven,
which is my favorite chapter in this book,
which has all of the examples and the
different verticals which are look at
unfortunately, you know, when I
talked to my editor said, you know,
you need to prepare them for this. You
can't expect every reader to, you know,
be at Google or Amazon or Facebook.
So if we had these sort of six
chapters leading up to it, um,
and one of them is data to
a ca as I just mentioned it.
So actually this book data for the
people is really meant for the people.
And I don't only teach at Berkeley,
I also teach in China.
And um,
I'm not sure how dubious honor it was
that people's daily had a long interview
with me, published on the front
page about data for the people.
I don't switch Annie's,
I don't know what it really says.
I can only feel the
worst, but uh, you know,
people's Daily and data for the people
sounds on the surface structure at least
kind of similar.
So why did a write the book?
I wrote the book because I realized when
I was at Amazon and each and every one
of you,
I'm sure it has the same utilization.
He had Google that the refineries,
as I call them,
the data refineries like Google,
that they,
without even trying hard,
no so much about us,
about us as individuals that I
think it is a wrong battle to fight.
The wrong battle is to try to plug
the holes and maybe being a good year.
A good story for this is Google maps
from the early days where I was told from
Salford involved in that meeting
that somebody hacked Google maps and
immediately idea came well
rather than plugging that hole,
how couldn't we make back to feature?
How can we make it possible for
people to actually amend data?
So that thinking that you don't try to
really stop the in stoppable but you see
what can we create of it?
That is the underlying thought which I
very much embraced and I hope that the
readers of the book will
also get a feeling about why.
I think embracing the data and being
empowered by the data is what I think are
better choices rather than
the romanticizing the view
of how good it was when we
could have control of our data.
And you know,
taking back these all these metaphors,
taking back control,
I mean we never had control of our data.
So hey, we can't possibly have control.
Imagine a week without Google.
You know, you could stay home, you
wouldn't have to come into work, but boy,
how would you get stuff done? I
mean, what would staff be? So for me,
when I see Sue's later revolution,
that really is a revolution which
is affected billions people's lives.
No question. We of course think about
information differently. Google,
we think about stuff, we
buy it differently. Amazon,
I mean who of you would not look at a
review before they choose a certain item?
By the way,
if anybody wants to review the book,
Amazon is open off or reviews and I
think it's a very important ingredient.
Thirdly,
in everything about who you are,
there's potentially take Google plus or
maybe Facebook or if you're in China,
we chat that has changed the way a
billion people think about who they are.
I would argue.
So the general framework is how can we
work together the refineries and the
individuals to figure out what
can we create for the individuals.
So Google of course has the longterm
you that if you have the choice,
but making a quick buck now or
having a consumer in the long term,
you of course go for the long term.
So in some way I'm
preaching to the choir here,
but I still want to go back
to the question and the thing,
it's a question worth asking people.
What would you do if you didn't
have access to Google for a day?
And then people realize
just how much would break
and it wouldn't even find him staying
with a friend of mine who works for me,
diamonds, I wouldn't even find
the place without Google maps.
And then I was trying to really get out
to people that necessity that it is,
I need to tell Google where I want to go.
Otherwise Google cannot tell me turn left
at the the next, the next intersection.
So I really part of data literacy,
hope that we can upgrade the conversation
from people that those logical things
that you know in the restaurant and
oh I pay after I eat or whatever.
Better examples you might have that
those also applied to data and if you go
into a cab and not sure where the Nfu
straight it and the Cabbie asks you where
are,
can I take you and said,
oh I'm not telling you that would be
probably invading my privacy and is not
going very far.
And now what I think by first of the six
rights I wanted to talk about is it is
a right to access your data.
Now I see all of you nodding and
a former president Obama also set,
this is the right to access
your data as an important right.
It is not as trivial as it sounds because
it clearly isn't just access to the
bits and the bytes.
So I was in Shanghai,
actually these people,
People's Daily was at my place
interviewing me and I showed them location
history on Google. So
I shoot them, you know,
you go into history and location and it
has to pick a date. And they said, Oh wow,
that is so amazing. Wow.
That was something beyond,
they could believe that a company giving
back or is returning to the user in
exchange to, you know,
showing me more relevant nets.
And I by the [inaudible] I used to
show Google latitude on my webpage on
viagen.com and yes,
indeed there were a situation that
Remming one dinner where ours, you know,
traffic is something,
I was chairman of the bay area pretty
late and a tool to the other parties and
you know, I'd be there five
minutes is that you won't,
I know you are still
in one oh one. So, uh,
that right to access to
data is very important.
One building tools that allow people to
get meaning out of the acts of the data
is where I think the most important
part comes from just raw here is all the
data out of Facebook,
doesn't help anything.
Building an awesome tour likes
Google location history. Um,
search history.
I think it's about,
for me at least the last thing you know,
I would be willing to share my search
history and honestly I don't think anybody
who thinks about it
would think differently.
You can have all my text messages and
have all my email but my searches.
But you have them already. So I mean, um,
eh building tools that help
people understand that data.
Since this is an educated crowd here,
one of my favorite sayings is
to make the implicit explicit.
The two meanings to it.
One is in all the data which I
look at all the searches I do,
making implicit patterns,
showing them to me,
I think that at least is fun and might
actually help me also make some decisions
like the hours of the day when I
searched or the days of the week,
things like that. The topics. Topics
are always very hard to classify it,
but making implicit patterns explicit is
part of giving somebody access to their
data.
The second part or the secondary mutation
of make the implicit explicit is that
as a company you write down
a function for this search,
right?
Events where you figure out what are the
ways to evaluate whether if we do this
kind of eyewear them or that
kind of, I would, you know,
this primary a treat
versus that primary trick,
which one actually do we believe
is better in the long term.
So into this with a called
equation of business,
you bake in an incredible
amount of assumptions,
but you make explicit,
and Amazon,
I spent probably 50 hours who stiff visas
for each group to figure out what is
the which quoted fitness function that
they should be evaluated by and has have
a buy in. And they're all, those are
mistakes. You always forget something.
And then of course smart people go and
optimize for that. And he said, Oh yes,
right? But that of course we
didn't mean. So, for example,
if someone says, you know,
we want to increase conversion rates,
so you turn after the first sale of
the year, you turn your service off.
No more sales, but a hundred percent
conversion rate. So you know, it's,
it's a constant process
and make it explicit.
It's something which I think is super
useful for the company and it really
condenses the thinking and reasonable
people absolutely can disagree on things.
But then once you have it, you
know, and the new crank, the handle,
whether this experiment or
that experiment is better.
So the first ride is
right to access your data.
Let me throw another wrench into it.
Your data.
So let's say a Facebook. So today, uh,
I am on NPR marketplace tech
and there are lots of comments.
Now if I change the post,
I have my Facebook a Vegas.
If I change the post summit, if I change
it a lot, then suddenly, you know,
some of the comments people make
don't make sense anymore. You know,
I might be learning from some of the
comments I might incorporate into my
Facebook post. Now they look really
stupid. So whose data is this?
So our ownership concept that you know,
works for apples or even for,
for physical books here,
that ownership concept
clearly breaks down for data.
So I don't have a solution which I a,
you must do it this way,
but I do see a couple of directions how
people should think about it differently.
And it clearly,
you might've heard the example last year,
which I think is a beautiful one off fed
monkey that took a picture of himself,
that Selfie and you know,
then the photographer sued uh,
Wikimedia or whoever published the
picture because they said, you know,
it was not taken by human.
So these are just very interesting
topics which I love for us as society to
discuss. And the ownership
of data from me and images.
Data is one of the examples where
I really feel, let's actually no,
not run away from it and please
let's not run away and say, oh,
the lawyer's a hundred years ago
they wrote down how to treat it.
They had no fricking idea of what we
have now is a good starting point.
But let's work together and
actually make it better.
Um, access to my data.
I have one more story.
It's not in the book.
Um,
there is a German paper which is called
[inaudible] and it's the largest paper
in the western hemisphere would do is
have dd publication and not particularly
the lecture shall we say. And
the head, the editor and chief,
um,
came to class in Brooklyn and uh,
we had dinner and someone took a
picture and post it in Facebook.
I was barely starting on the bay bridge
when my phone rang and the tats and more
left wing paper called me up and said,
we saw a picture.
We need to do interviews.
It absolutely.
And what happened was then they said,
we just have one question.
Who has the most power
over you as a consumer?
Apple.
Amazon,
Facebook, Google. What do you think?
Anybody would not say? Google. Raise
your hand. Oh yeah. Who Do you think
your friends, we talked
about companies. Okay. Uh,
I don't know whether Google has more
power over me than my friends because you
know,
let's say Google wants to let me
disappear or remove me from the index.
Yeah, we knew this guy, Andrea says, not
even any trace left of him. Not a problem.
And I actually, you all are familiar
with the right to be forgotten.
The de linking,
which by the way in terms of raw numbers
is nothing compared to copyright things.
Google has to deal with by,
you know,
companies complaining that
something was used illegally.
I want not a right to be forgotten.
I want to write to be remembered.
So for me,
the right to access for data means also
the right to remember some suicidal
agreement that hey and who is doing a
very good job in that, that you know,
I want my old emails to not
sort of random disappear.
Big Difference to China.
So I gave a talk at a company in December
and I wonder to pull up on we chat,
which is sort of Tencent's version of
Facebook. It's a communication tool.
I want to put up on Richard a picture.
Somebody else had posted with me
and Jack Ma maybe two weeks prior,
not thinking anything of at this,
this picture is no longer available.
It might've been removed by the
whatever the portion is posted.
Of course all in Chinese,
you don't know what it means
to us with what does it mean.
And I felt really violated that
there something which I do to,
you know,
get them good traffic and then two weeks
later I give this nebulous message by
this picture is no longer available.
Now of course it's a question
a hundred years probably.
I have no problem with that.
Two weeks I do have a with that.
So I really brought that up in
that crowd and was quite annoyed.
I mean sort of happens in real time.
I want to show them somebody is no
longer there really pushing what company
would you want to have taken care of?
Your data it company that
really has very good service,
that agreement and says the uptime
versus a company which, you know,
random delete stuff. And then they say,
oh, it's too expensive to, you know,
half a serve.
I mean that's as ridiculous as cost of
storage is not what difference it would
make for anybody. How much,
how much can you produce it?
A hundred bucks a yet very most.
And the Chinese said,
oh we would prefer that second company
and that is what really brought these
cultural bias is very much up
to the forefront of my thinking.
I'm familiar with Europe's,
I gave you the example right here
before gotten versus what we think here,
but the adage do was your data and that
they they embrace in a femoral nature.
Whereas I,
I grew up in a world where you know,
I could fix these things are there and
you can attach them who can access them.
So sometimes our biases might just be
representing us well and other people in
the word think about it differently.
And two nights ago I had dinner
with Dan economen and I asked him,
why do you think that's the case?
And he thought maybe it
is that the attitude was
accountability is different in
the US compared to China.
That they are very happy not to blame it
on the computer, which is not an excuse.
Probably any of us would accept if
somebody says, you know a Checkin,
I'm sorry the computer made a mistake.
No it's not the computer,
which made me see somebody made a mistake,
not the computer.
The other point I want to make,
and that's the last one on this
right here to access your data is uh,
in comparison with your tie in the US,
this huge experiment of running Facebook
for an a billion people and running.
We chat for B and people and uh,
I don't know who of you has been on Wechat
or too few people in that case.
Let me just say very generally
that the assumption for instance,
that if you are friends you usually
can see the friends we have in common,
which seems that get perfectly good
thing for me. That after all, you know,
if we have friends in common,
if if mutual friends,
then why would I hide my
mutual friends from you?
I think this data symmetry as Jordan Novat
wrote it in a wonderful article a few
years ago. This data symmetry is
the way I think fantasist built.
No way we should would ever
show you any buddies, friends.
So it's a bit like my PR agent that they
don't give me his number because you
know I might disintermediate them,
not think that you know,
when we meet I could actually ask you for
a number so they might as well make it
frictionless and make
it easier and you know,
see for some potential there be,
this connects off saying hey be
introduced and you take it from here.
So that wrong notion about having
power booth withholding data,
it's the notion of how
the word used to work.
Companies got big by erecting barriers
to inflammation and that's how money used
to be made. Like used car
dealers as an example. Now,
if you're thinking about the
companies who know and love,
they got big by removing barriers to
information and I just love as far as,
I love when the sign
flips and another sign,
flip example in this world is when
I was an Undergrad in Germany,
we were not allowed to unplug our phones.
So the role of the government was to
protect the network from the consumer.
And luckily at least under
the previous administration,
there have been moves to actually produce
a proactive consumer from the network.
So signed flips is something
I'd love to talk about more.
I have a few examples in the book.
I think just very interesting
when something doesn't
change by 10% but changes
aside from plus to minus or minus or plus
five more rights to go.
The second right is the right
to inspect the refineries.
So when you buy a car
or fridge or whatever,
typically there are some things like
stickers on it that help you make a
decision.
For instance,
the fuel efficiency or
how loud the fridges, no,
these are numbers which EPA or other
groups agree on how to measure it.
So it's not just one person just,
you know, puts Niya and says, oh,
you know that fridges out.
That would be the current administration's
that's true to this. But no,
they had scientists and they actual fig
out without being gagged how they can
actually come up with this number.
So you as a consumer can compare them.
I would the same for refineries
for data refineries have not,
of course not fuel efficiency,
but you know how secure is my data.
So it has no question when you know,
people not easily come and say, oh,
I would not put the data up in
the cloud if she goes in Shanghai.
When I heard that argument, what do
you like using docs here from China?
What if Google can see what you're
writing? Say, you know, they see anyways,
besides there's the Chinese government,
so don't fool yourself.
Don't live the illusion
that they don't know.
But we have extremely strong economic
constructs that companies do not want to
be broken into. Because as you saw
in Sony's example, for instance,
it can be very expensive.
And if there ever was a security issue,
which affected consumers at that say one
of the top companies that said Google
versus Amazon, that really would
I think be an extraordinary,
terrible thing for the company if
suddenly seems that you did it safely.
Voice is absolutely aligned of interest
of the consumer and the company against
the hackers and the criminals.
Um,
I was for my birthday last year,
I was in Moscow November 10,
and then met with Putin and uh,
I spent the day with the head of spare
bank, which is the largest bank there,
which he owns a certain part off.
And uh, the head of that bank,
how on graph, very smart individual. Um,
he was caught out half halfway through
and he came back in town. I said,
what happened while we had an attack on
our service and I was thinking, you know,
if any would tax it would be the
Russians or maybe the Tony is so awesome.
So where did it come from?
Of course when the United States,
I mean like where else would recovering
from that it makes you think, Huh,
we do have a certain word who here? It
makes sense once you start thinking about,
so a part of this right to inspect the
refineries means that you can look in
what is being done to use two factor
authentication for email. You know,
do you, I mean there's now these
things we did applied to Google,
but not all companies
are as good as Google.
So that is stickers not for your fridge,
but stick us for your refinery.
Allowing users to make decisions of
whether the rather more convenience like
when his passwords, you know,
you can just direct, you know,
we do email versus a more security.
Let people make the trade off.
The remaining four rights
are the right to amend.
That means I believe, I believe in
democracy. I believe in, you know,
giving people a voice.
I believe in empowering people and not
by controlling how the truth would be.
Alternative facts should be.
So that means let anybody
annotate anything.
So if you think
x about y make a link on y where you
are saying x and then you as the hundred
billion dollar machinery
of relevance ranking,
whether it's Google or whether
it's Amazon recommendations,
Netflix use that hundred
bend or I machinery,
which she was very well for
ads use that for amendments.
So basically anybody should be able to
say anything and quickly things that
actually seem to be right or
interesting maybe you know,
interesting more than right.
They will bubble up and uh,
that is very short.
The right to amend.
Next one,
the second off fees.
Action Rights is the right to blur,
blur judications the best example but
it also works for searches of a products
you buy that you should be in charge
of the radius of the granularity,
the resolution in which data that
concern you can be processed.
In all cases.
It was very,
very important to me is that people
understand the trade offs they are making.
The world is not black or white.
So if you say,
I am going to Burma,
geolocation to one kilometer,
don't expect the pizza delivery
man to bring it to your door.
So Hey, if you really want this, then you
can't want that and just live up to it.
But don't live that illusion of these
lottery inconsistencies that you don't
want anybody to know where you are,
but you would like to pizza to be devoted
to one and assess the super trivial
example.
But this right to blur your
data is important for me
and the illusion people have is that
they can sort of blur data at the source.
I don't believe in that.
I think the carriers for instance,
Google of course knows to the resolution
of less than a meter where I'm pretty
much 24,
seven.
It of course knows what time waking up it
of course knows what I'm interested in.
All these things.
You can't do anything at the source.
That's why I think having the right where
you are in charge of figuring out how
precisely you want the things to be known,
that really should be your choice.
Now there is,
um,
there are some interesting things from
psychology. So for instance, weren't up,
uh,
wonder to figure out 20 years ago,
who of you knows what
differential privacies
Soso okay. It's a very important
concept that if I tell you something,
so you can,
let's say as a government for instance,
make it better policy discussion.
I wanted to be protected that
you can't use it against me.
So my belief really is data off
the people, data by the people,
but data for the people.
So if let's say somebody asks,
um,
you know,
as we had with the previous pride
president who took something but he didn't
inhale, so, uh, did you
smoke pot last month?
And let's say you are in a state where
it's illegal smoke point. So if you say,
I did, and then the next day
the police shows up and says,
you said you smoked pot after
prison. I mean, it's not that bad.
But think about other things,
which would be this way that would suck
that you try to have some policy to help
them understanding.
So that die guy called Werner had the
idea that I'd asked you a question about,
don't not say it,
he is a coin and uh,
you flipped the coin and I don't want
to know what would you feel if you get
heads, you say yes, irrespective
of what you really did.
If you get tails,
you have to say the truth.
That's pretty cool because more than
half of the people say yes. So, uh,
it's clear to any prosecutor that
they can't go after these people.
And if we have enough statistics,
you know,
any of you can do the math about how to
figure out the signal given that 50% of
the people only say the truth and the
other cs irrespectively of what actually
happened.
So I encourage you to look a bit
into this differential privacy ideas,
which help us get data for the people
where we set it up in a way that you can't
use it against them. Who would
does it? When you need chrome,
where you are looking at what people do,
where you try to spend a
malware on people's computers.
It's a similar concept where smart people
came up with ways finding out things
about the population which cannot
be used against the individual.
The fifth right
is the right,
I wanted to quite have the right to play
and my editor said that is, you know,
maybe not serious enough.
So who we call it the right to experiment.
In 1989,
I started a company called logic it
little startup with the purpose of music
recommendations.
It was an interesting time also with the
founding media of Pandora and they went
different routes.
Um,
how did a company got bought by
or media which would gold by the,
by another company.
So the idea was we want to first of all
figure out not from the metadata part,
from the usage pattern of how
people skip between songs,
what we should recommend and then,
and I really haven't seen that elsewhere.
We want to make explicit to people
the trade off between
exploration and exploitation.
So in machine learning,
one of the things where you can
just hope the system will, you know,
come up with a solution is
whether you should explore more.
I mean you can try out new things that
you don't know where they're good or bad
that you know this one armed
bandit problem in Vegas. You know,
if one machine once gave you some money,
will you spend the rest of the day
on that one machine, POCs, POCs,
or are you going to still explore
some other machines might be bad,
better or might be voice
exploration versus exploitation.
So that is a knob which I think
should be headed to the consumer,
to the user goes,
I know whether I had a stressful day and
all I wanted to some soothing music or
like an airplane, you know, we'll check
in three hours, delay every 10 minutes.
Yeah, update the departure by 10
minutes and you don't sit anywhere.
You really just want something which
is now a quiet or am I in the mood to
explore new stuff? Let me listen to
things I've never listened to before.
Chances are hated, but she has also
are that or discover something new.
So that's one example is when I say do
right to play or the right to experiment
is think how you can expose to the user
some of the knobs where you don't know
the answer as well as use it does.
So exploration expert is one example.
In search advanced search you have a few
options which are a step in the right
direction,
but I think they can read more by helping
people to actually set the privatest
they way they want to set them on
their terms, any given point in time.
And then we have all the data,
we've got to look at them.
But that's not enough for me.
I want to be able to
take the data to of ips.
So I call this the right to port.
I would put my data and eh,
we know,
we all know PGP and API closes up.
So just implement it in a reasonable way
that if some other company would offer
a better search product,
then make it easy for me to actually
take my data in a secure way.
Telling them here is what the data is.
And I think it helps the ecosystem because
those companies which are good people
will come back, make it easy for people
to actually put the data on trial.
Something else you can always
learn from who is coming back.
It's another feedback loop
in experiments you're doing.
So that's what I wanted to say about
those six rights which are wrote about in
the book. And I thought she only dodge to
book you on to two days ago. I have not.
We talked about it yet and I've never
really spent as much time except in class
on those rights.
So I want to end
with the couple of things which
I do not have answers for. Great.
So,
uh, questions. Hi. Thank you for
coming. Thanks for having me.
So, uh, when you talk about the
right to blur in particular,
that made me think of one of the current
problems is that a lot of us who come
from fairly privileged backgrounds
thinking about, oh, this is a great,
I can just share my information,
what could possibly go wrong?
But the immense power of doxing has
been shown to be a force against people.
And what's worse is the farther we go
towards the default us sharing all your
information. Oh, but maybe you,
we'll blur your location for
safety and can't get pizza.
You start to create like a
digital underclass, right?
You can force people out of this
glorious data world for their own safety.
Do you,
do you have any thoughts on that?
Um,
I think it was a lunch when we talked
about that there was a time when,
for instance, Harvey Milk was
shot. There was a time when,
you know, the first gay bar in San
Francisco, they didn't have windows.
Um, so people could look in. Um,
and I think that social norm norms
ultimately is what determines our attitude
towards many things.
Let me twist it slightly.
Hine who used to be at Google now
runs data for snapchat and a B,
then a couple of weeks.
And I think that's quite interesting that
on the surface you have things being a
femoral, of course, the deep
structures so that the data is there.
Is that ultimately helping or hurting?
And you knew the story,
which was reporting in the Guardian
that it, one of the services.
It was a thing secret. Ehm, you know,
not everything was a s s s Ephemera
as they claimed it was. [inaudible].
So, I don't know. Do
you have any suggestion?
Nope. Still working on that? Yeah. Um,
I um,
right after my phd,
um, I wanted to teach in Thailand
at the university for half a year,
so when to cheer on corn. And, um,
two things I learned from that one
is that my friends told me that his
scientific suicide,
if you are as three things,
one is Peter Norvig.
Andrew knew at the time already scientific
suicide if you are going to be out of
touch for half a year. And you
know, it was a different time.
Um,
so when I came half a year
later back to us to know,
most people had noticed
that actually Wisconsin,
um, uh, those days,
the underclass email go deliver to
Thailand twice a day by dialing taka,
Taka,
Taka.
We one connection to Melbourne from the
Asian Institute of Technology in Bangkok
to Mebane and getting the email
for the country back and forth.
And there was two weeks when we didn't
have email and then some dude showed up
at my office too long gone.
I think I do only Spock station at the
university should up with uh, you know,
I'm not sure whether,
you know,
these cartridges they used to have
sure shows up to the coverages.
This is the email for the
country for the last two weeks.
Uh, so I, uh, I had never, you know,
doubt with SMTP every note
we can learn anything.
So I've posted the obvious thing,
which just I grabbed for my name and like
the first 10 things were other people
talking about me at that stage. I said,
this is not a profit I'm going to solve.
I don't want to know what people are
talking about me, basically, you know. Uh,
I didn't expect that to be able to,
I thought I just see where I'm the two
line and out as quickly scan through
those.
And the search thing
too was that I had hoped
that
the digital divide would
get bridged with those days,
the Internet then you know,
later the web and I am not sure about it.
Um,
what I am sure about is that another
comparison between the US and China is of
course the great firewall.
It clearly makes my life worse.
Every time I go to China.
It is last time the Latin male,
they're like six weeks a year and asked
time was less happy than ever because
things which used to be easy,
just becoming incredibly hard.
And even things like using apps in
China like dd which is you are the lifts
equivalent. If you don't read
Chinese, you got us host.
Another question. Uh, you talked about uh,
the right to annotate the right to a man,
but what about the truth?
Uh,
should they not have the
right to read FECC based?
Very tricky.
I totally agree.
And I was sort of halfway
mentioned fake fake news before.
I believe, as I said, that
be $100 billion engine,
which we have figured out
for search relevance that
that can also figure out the
truth if we wanted.
Yeah,
that's my believe in if we
have enough data sources,
if you have the identity
of people who postings,
if you know that desk person thinking
about Wikipedia who gets reverted and
stuff, I guess I think we
can build pretty good models.
It will never be perfect,
but what is the alternative?
So it is not that.
The alternative is that we have Donald
Trump telling us how it really is,
but the alternative is that you know,
some random stuff, what happened,
I believe in,
in in masters and intelligent machines
and editors or freaking out what actually
is a more likely version of the truth.
Then one person dictating it.
But that brings me to one of the
two heart problems at the end,
which is the question of identity.
So underlying here is that you have your
Gmail account or you have your Amazon
account. So when you write those reviews
about my book to dimension reviews them,
when you write those reviews,
then your identity is there.
And actually I went as an Amazon,
we had very good discussions with
Jeff basis where I was wrong.
I believe juice ref pseudonyms
because I did not want actually,
you know, a colleague if I write
a bad review about his book,
knowing that that is undress and
you know, that would not, you know,
really further our
relationship or that much.
I really believe to pseudonyms and
Jeff says, no, we need real names.
So Facebook probably gave him
right that, you know, real names.
It's an open question.
I don't have no,
I just want to say the question about
should one institution hold, uh,
the identity,
what should that institution be?
In my last class I had
in Brooklyn in November,
I had two wonderful guest speakers.
One former NSA employee and a
lawyer for the Acru David Holtzman.
He wrote a wonderful book called
privacy loss 10 years ago.
He knows what he's talking
about and Nicole Ozar,
wonderful person went to
Berkeley Law who really,
Austin knows what she knows.
And she busted a few operations where,
you know,
Facebook for instance, handed over
via some third party company, um,
data to the law enforcement so they could,
you know,
use your spare resources better.
You know,
so we had the conversation ended
accumulate in the question, which I asked.
So it was my youtube channel,
youtube.com/social data revolution and
the repeated in Moscow for Putin in front
of that audience.
Who Do you think will be around longer?
The oldest states of America or Google?
Almost all the students believed Google.
But then in the bigger picture,
to come to my last point,
you know,
good or played on 2000 years ago,
he talked about the allegory of the cave.
And the idea was that people in his case,
prisoners,
I don't like that matter metaphor much,
but prisoners for him, we're sitting,
they couldn't move their heads for the
entire lives and they were only looking
at the wall of a cave.
And that ball had shadows,
as we would call them,
had dark things projected.
There was a light source behind them.
You know,
like you don't denied somebody if they
didn't have that concept cause all this
or where the shadows on the wall,
no shadows were puppets.
Maybe some holes Kang Round, or maybe
were people behind them. They didn't know.
And there were certain laws which
they figured out, for instance,
not tool or nonfat fatty Altus seem
to the Romans who would've said later,
which means nature doesn't jump around.
So there was continuity in those
shadows in there, had their, would you,
they pat their stories about that.
They couldn't turn their heads, but,
and then one of the
prisoners were set free.
So he left war.
There was all that light
out there and it hurt him.
He, he, and he went back
and said, that's it. No,
not doing that again.
So the word we live in is the
world according to Google.
The word we live in the West is
the word according to Facebook.
So all I can say is use
that responsibility wisely.
Thank you.